Traducteur: Aurélie Bartholomée
Relecteur: eric vautier
Mon histoire commence il y a deux ans.
J'étudiais chez mes grands-parents
pour mes examens de janvier,
comme tout bon étudiant.
C'était une session assez intense ;
mais à cette époque,
je me suis plutôt lancée dans une
session intense de procrastination.
(Rires)
Vous savez, ce moment
où vous regardez plein de vidéos
sur des sujets vraiment intéressants
qui n'ont rien à voir avec ce que
vous devez étudier ?
C'est ce que je faisais.
Mais pendant que je regardais
vidéo sur vidéo,
je suis tombée sur
un TED talk bien particulier.
Une femme de 23 ans, Lauren Singer,
qui, sur l'espace de trois ans,
n'a produit que l'équivalent d'un bocal,
comme vous l'avez vu,
de déchets.
Dire que je me trouvais écologique.
Imaginez donc ma tête
quand je suis descendue
et que j'ai réalisé que j'avais pris
un jus d'orange par jour
accompagné d'une paille en plastique
ces trois dernières semaines.
Trois semaines fois sept jours -
un total de 21 pailles en plastique.
Et ce total de 21 pailles en plastique
m'a fait comprendre une chose importante :
pour changer le monde,
il faut commencer par soi-même.
Ne pas simplement demander ce que
nos politiciens font pour sauver la Terre,
mais aussi ce que vous pouvez faire
pour sauver la Terre.
Je pense que chacun d'entre nous
a le pouvoir de changer le monde,
et si pas le monde entier,
au moins votre monde individuel,
votre entourage personnel.
Et c'est l'addition
de ces mondes individuels
qui va finir par changer le monde entier.
Une recherche européenne menée
dans la mer du Nord
a trouvé que
98% des oiseaux marins analysés
avaient ingéré du plastique,
et que 43% des déchets trouvés
sur les plages européennes
sont issus de plastique à usage unique.
Du plastique que nous n'utilisons
qu'une fois, puis jetons.
Nous ne le réalisons pas, mais tous
les jours, du plastique est produit,
et s'accumule à ce tas immense,
et le simple fait de jeter quelque chose
ne signifie pas que cette chose disparaît.
C'est juste qu'on ne la voit plus.
Et c'est quand j'ai réalisé ça
que j'ai eu besoin que ça change.
Je vous raconte tout ça,
mais nous sommes tous au courant, non ?
Au courant de ce qu'engendre le plastique,
au courant de la problématique climatique.
Alors comment ça se fait
que nous soyons si peu
à agir de manière proactive ?
N'est-il pas temps que nous faisions
notre possible pour renverser la donne ?
Tout le monde a des idées en tête,
et je suis sûre qu'en écoutant
tous ces TED Talks ce soir,
vous en avez au moins eu une bonne.
La question que je pose maintenant est :
« Qu'allez-vous faire de cette idée ? »
Avec les petits tracas du quotidien,
nous avons tendance à oublier
ce qui nous est vraiment important.
Historien et activiste, Robert Swan dit :
« La plus grande menace pour notre planète
est la croyance que
quelqu'un d'autre va la sauver. »
Et comme je disais,
nos problèmes individuels à court terme
nous font oublier ce qui compte vraiment
pour nous,
mais nous font aussi oublier
les grandes problématiques,
laissant leur gestion à d'autres personnes
en pensant qu'ils vont les résoudre.
Ce soir, je suis là pour vous montrer
et vous prouver
que vous pouvez être cette autre personne,
que vous pouvez changer le monde.
Et c'est alors que j'ai réalisé
que bien que je me dise écolo, en théorie,
je devais cesser de parler,
et agir concrètement.
Avoir une idée ne suffit pas.
Donc,
je vous partage
une petite histoire personnelle
et qui a déclenché
cette prise de conscience,
cette décision d'agir.
La voici.
Un jour, je reçois un coup de fil
de ma mère.
« Fanny, un colis de 25 kg
vient d'être livré à la maison.
Peux-tu m'expliquer ce qu'il se passe ? »
Ma maman.
Vous auriez dû voir sa tête
quand elle a réalisé
que ce colis de 25 kg
contenait 600 pailles en acier inoxydable.
(Bravos) (Applaudissements)
Et vous vous dites sûrement
que je savais exactement
ce que j'allais faire de ces 600 pailles.
Pas du tout.
Bien sûr, j'avais une idée,
mais comment j'allais la mettre en œuvre,
ça, je n'en savais rien.
Et c'est en racontant cette anecdote
à la fille assise à côté de moi
à l'université -
à qui je n'avais d'ailleurs jamais parlé
auparavant -
qu'elle a vu le potentiel derrière l'idée.
Manuela est devenue la co-fondatrice
de notre projet WAW,
qui est l'acronyme de
« What About Waste ».
Pourquoi est-elle importante ?
Parce qu'elle,
au lieu de voir la grande pile de déchets
et les grandes problématiques de ce monde,
a vu ce qu'il y avait moyen de faire
en tant qu'individu,
lentement mais sûrement, jour après jour,
pour changer notre petite communauté.
Alors qu'est-ce que WAW exactement ?
L'idée de base est simple,
et c'est quelque chose que j'ai compris
au long de mon périple :
les gens n'ont pas le temps
ou ne sont pas assez intéressés
que pour se soucier de l'environnement
au quotidien.
Alors,
nous avons proposé
de retourner la question.
S'ils n'ont pas envie d'être écologiques
ou n'ont simplement pas le temps,
nous y penserons à leur place.
Nous avons donc pris les 600 pailles
en acier inoxydable,
et sommes passées
de restaurant en restaurant,
leur proposant ces petites pailles
comme alternatives à celles en plastique
à usage unique.
Notre solution :
échangez vos pailles en plastique
contre des pailles en acier inoxydable.
Mais je sais que la problématique
du plastique à usage unique
est plus vaste
que les pailles en plastique.
Mais, avec celles en acier inoxydable,
elles font office de symbole
de toutes les choses que nous pouvons
faire dans notre quotidien
pour adopter un mode de vie plus propre.
Notre but ultime
est de rendre le mode de vie
durable et écologique
plus facile et même moins cher
que le mode de vie « gaspilleur ».
Et je suis convaincue
que nous y arriverons.
La question des pailles en plastique
s'est répandue tellement vite
à travers le monde -
de nombreux pays l'abordent,
même dans les médias,
ce qui prouve que lorsque nous agissons
ensemble contre nos problèmes,
nous pouvons obtenir
des résultats considérables.
Honnêtement, je suis surprise
de l'impact de WAW.
Le projet n'a commencé qu'il y a un an,
et aujourd'hui, WAW s'est répandu
à trois autres pays,
sept villes,
et, actuellement, à plus de 90 restaurants
qui ont décidé de nous suivre et
de bannir les pailles en plastique.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Je ne suis pas juste une entrepreneuse.
Je suis aussi - et très fermement -
une environnementaliste.
Voyez-moi plutôt
comme une « greenpreneur »,
« l'entrepreneuse environnementaliste ».
Et je pense qu'il est important
que chacun de nous agisse.
Car oui, nous avons le pouvoir -
avec notre argent,
avec nos actions quotidiennes -
de montrer aux grandes institutions
que nous voulons du changement,
que nous ne sommes pas satisfaits
de la situation actuelle.
Imaginez ceci.
Imaginez-vous après une longue
et pénible journée de travail.
Ce qui n'est pas très difficile.
Vous allez dans votre salle de bain,
et vous tournez le robinet du bain,
parce que vous méritez un bon bain chaud.
Ce n'est d'ailleurs pas très écologique,
donc essayez de ne pas le faire
trop souvent.
Mais vous tournez ce robinet,
vous oubliez que l'eau coule,
et quand vous revenez précipitamment,
vous trouvez votre salle de bain
complètement inondée.
Que faites-vous ?
Allez-vous d'abord chercher des seaux
et réparer tous les dégâts ?
Ou fermez-vous d'abord le robinet
pour ensuite commencer à nettoyer ?
Qui aurait d'abord coupé l'eau ?
Levez la main.
Oui !
Une question très sensible évidemment.
Faisons un parallèle.
Pourquoi ne fermons-nous pas d'abord
les vannes de la production de plastique ?
Je suis la plus grande défenseuse de -
oui, merci -
(Bravos)
Et je vous promets,
je suis la plus grande défenseuse
des nettoyages de plages,
et des marques de mode réutilisant
du plastique et des textiles
pour créer de nouveaux articles.
J'en porte un actuellement.
Mais -
et c'est un grand « mais »,
non pas « mes »
mais « mais »
(Rires)
Mais ne pensez-vous pas qu'en parallèle,
nous devrions juste couper les vannes ?
(Rires)
WAW le fait en empêchant les clients
qui mangent dans nos restaurants
d'utiliser des pailles en plastique.
Dans nos restaurants partenaires,
vous n'en verrez aucune
dans votre boisson.
Mais nous avons besoin de plus de WAW
à l'échelle mondiale.
Imaginez si chacun d'entre vous ici
et dans le monde,
avec vos idées géniales
pour changer le monde,
les mettiez en œuvre de manière concrète.
Imaginez si vous, Monsieur, créiez
le WAW pour des couverts comestibles.
Et si vous, Madame, créiez le WAW
pour les plats à emporter.
Imaginez seulement l'impact
que vous auriez.
Et, procrastinatrice que je suis,
j'ai créé mon WAW,
alors il n'y a pas de raisons
que vous ne puissiez pas créer le vôtre.
Barack Obama a dit :
« Nous sommes la première génération à
ressentir l'impact du changement climatique
mais nous sommes aussi la dernière
qui puisse agir pour y remédier. »
Alors remédions-y.
Agissons.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)